i think we try to bring this question up
a couple of times
uh but let's return to it again is what
do you think is the difference between
the way a computer
represents information the human genome
represents and stores information
like what and maybe broadly what is the
difference between
how you think about computers and how
you think about biological systems
so i made a very provocative claim
earlier that we are a digital computer
like that at the core lies a digital
code and that's true in many ways but
surrounding that digital core there's a
huge amount of analog
if you look at our brain it's not really
digital if you look at our sort of
rna and all of that stuff inside
ourselves it's not really digital it's
really
analog in many ways but let's start with
the code and then we'll expand
to the rest so the code itself is
digital
so there's genes you can think of the
genes as i don't know the
procedures the functions inside your
language and then
somehow you have to turn these functions
on how do you call a gene how do you
call that function the way that you
would do it in old
programming languages is go to address
whatever in your memory and then you
start running from there
and you know modern programming
languages have encapsulated
this into functions and objects and all
of that and it's nice and cute but in
the end deep down
there's still an assembly code that says
go to that instruction and it runs that
instruction
if you look at the human genome and you
know the genome of pretty much
most species out there it's
there's no go-to function you just don't
start
in you know transcribing in position
thirteen
hundred five you know thirteen thousand
five hundred twenty seven in
chromosome 12. you instead have
content based indexing so at every
location
in the genome in front of the genes that
need to be turned on
i don't know when you drink coffee
there's a little coffee marker
in front of all of them and whenever
your
cells that metabolize coffee need to
metabolize coffee they basically see
coffee and they're like oh
let's go turn on all the coffee marked
genes so
there's basically these small motifs
these small sequences
that we call regulatory motifs they're
like patterns of dna they're only
eight characters long or so like gat gca
etc and these motifs
work in combinations and every one of
them has
some recruitment affinity for a
different protein
that will then come and bind it and
together collections of these motifs
create regions that we call regulatory
regions
that can be either promoters near the
beginning of the gene
and that basically tells you where the
function actually starts where you call
it
and then enhancers that are looping
around of the dna
that basically bring the machinery that
binds those enhancers
and then bring it onto the promoter
which then
recruits the right sort of the ribosome
and the polymerase and all of that thing
which will first transcribe and then
export and then eventually translate in
the cytoplasm
you know whatever rna molecule so
the beauty
of the way that the digital computer
that's the genome works
is that it's extremely fault tolerant
if i took your hard drive and i messed
with 20
of the letters in it of those zeros and
ones and i flipped them
you'd be in trouble if i take the genome
and i flip 20
of the letters you probably won't even
notice
and that resilience that's fascinating
again is a
key design principle and again i'm
theromorphizing here
but it's a key driving principle of how
biological systems work
they're first resilient and then
anything else
and when you look at this incredible
beauty of
life from the most i don't know
beautiful i don't know human genome
maybe of humanity and all of the ideals
that should come with it
to the most terrifying genome like i
don't know covet 19
stars cov2 and the current pandemic
you basically see this elegance as
the epitome of clean design
but it's dirty it's a mess it's
you know the the way to get there is
hugely messy and that's something that
we as computer scientists
don't embrace we like to have clean code
you know as like in engineering they
teach you about compartmentalization
about sort of separating functions about
modularity about hierarchical design
none of that applies in bio testing
testing sure yeah biology does plenty of
that but i mean through evolutionary
exploration
but if you look at biological systems
first they are robust and then they
specialize to become anything else
and if you look at viruses the reason
why they're so
elegant when you look at the design of
this you know
genome it seems so elegant and
the reason for that is that it's been
stripped down from something much larger
because of the pressure to keep it
compact so many compact genomes out
there
have ancestors that were much larger you
don't start small and become big
you go through a loop of add a bunch of
stuff increase complexity
and then you know slim it down and one
of my early papers was in fact
on genome duplication one of the things
we found is that baker's yeast which is
the
you know yeast that you use to make
bread but also the yeast that you use to
make wine
which is basically the dominant species
when you go in the fields of tuscany and
you say you know what's out there
it's basically saccharomyces cerevisiae
or the way my italian friend says
so um which means what oh sakura
okay i'm sorry i'm i'm greek so yeah
zacharo mickeys zacharo is sugar
minky's is fungus yes cervicia cerveza
beer so it means the sugar fungus of
beer
yeah you know less less sound sounding
to the
still poetic yeah so anyway
saccharomyces cerevisiae basically the
major baker's yeast out there
is the descendant of a whole genome
duplication
why would a whole genuine duplication
even happen when it happened
is coinciding with about 100 million
years ago
and the emergence of
fruit-bearing plants
why fruit-bearing plants because animals
would eat
the fruit and would walk around and poop
huge amounts of nutrients along with a
seed
for the plants to spread before that
plants were not spreading through
animals they were spreading through wind
and all kinds of other ways but
basically the moment you have fruit
bearing plants
the the the these plants are basically
creating this abundance of sugar in the
environment so there's an evolutionary
niche that gets created
and in that evolutionary niche you
basically have enough sugar
that a whole genome duplication which
initially is a very messy event
allows you to then you know relieve some
of that complexity
so to pause uh what does genome
duplication mean
that basically means that instead of
having eight chromosomes
you can now have 16 chromosomes
so but with the duplication at first
when you have six when you go to 16
you're not using that oh yeah you are
yeah so basically from one day to the
next
you went from having eight chromosomes
to having 16 chromosomes
probably a non-disjunction event during
a duplication during a division
so you basically divide the cell instead
of half the genome going this way and
half the genome going the other way
after
duplication of the genome you basically
have all of it going to one cell
and then there's a sufficient messiness
there that you end up with
slight differences that make most of
these chromosomes be actually preserved
it's a long story short to me but it's a
big upgrade right so that's
not necessarily because what happens
immediately thereafter is that you start
massively
losing tons of those duplicated genes so
90
of those genes were actually lost very
rapidly after holding duplication
and the reason for that is that biology
is not intelligent
it's just ruthless selection
random mutation so the ruthless
selection basically means that as soon
as one of the random mutations hit one
gene
ruthless selection just kills off that
gene it's just you know
you you know if you have a pressure to
maintain a small compact genome
you will very rapidly lose the second
copy of most of your genes
and a small number 10 were kept in two
copies and those had to do a lot with
environment adaptation
with the speed of replication with the
speed of translation
and with sugar processing so i'm making
a long story short to basically say that
evolution is
messy the only way like so so
you know the example that i was giving
of messing with 20
of your bits in your computer totally
bogus
duplicating all your functions and just
throwing them out there in the same
you know function just totally bogus
like this would never work in an
engineer system
but biological systems because of this
content-based indexing and because of
this
modularity that comes from the fact that
the gene is controlled by a series of
tags and now if you need this gene in
another
setting you just add some more tags that
will basically turn it on
also in those settings so this gene is
now pressured
to do two different functions and it
builds up complexity
i say whole term duplication and gene
duplication in general as a way to
relieve that complexity
so you have this gradual build up of
complexity as function get
past get sort of added on to the
existing genes
and then boom you duplicate your your
workforce
and you now have two copies of this gene
one will probably specialize to do one
and the other one will specialize to do
the other or one will maintain the
ancestral function the other one will
sort of
be free to evolve and specialize while
losing the ancestral functions
and so forth so that's how genomes
evolve they're they're just
messy things but they're extremely fault
tolerant
and they're extremely able to deal with
mutations because that's the very way
that you generate
new functions so new functionalization
comes from
the very thing that breaks it so even in
the current pandemic
many people are asking me which
mutations matter the most
and what i tell them is well we can
study the evolutionary dynamics of the
current genome
to then understand which mutations have
previously happened or not and
which mutations happen in genes that
evolve rapidly or not
and one of the things we found for
example is that
the genes that evolved rapidly in the
past are still evolving rapidly now in
the current pandemic the genes have
evolved slowly in the past are still
evolving slowly which means that they're
useful
which means that they're under the same
evolutionary pressures
but then the question is what happens in
specific mutations
so if you look at the d614 gene mutation
that's been all over the news so
in position 614 in the amino acids 114
of the s protein there's a
d to g mutation that that sort of has
creeped over
the population that mutation
we found out through my work disrupts a
perfectly conserved nucleotide position
that has never been changed in the
history of
millions of years of equivalent
mammalian evolution
of these viruses that basically means
that it's a completely new adaptation
to human and that mutation has now gone
from
1 frequency to 90 frequency in almost
all outbreaks
so this mutation i like how you say in
the mu the
416 what was it okay yeah 6 on 14 sorry
614
d614g dc so so literally
so what you're saying is it's like a
chess move yeah so
it's just mutated one letter to another
exactly and that hasn't happened before
yeah and never and this somehow this
mutation is really useful
uh it's really useful in the current
environment of the genome
which is moving from human to human when
it was moving from bad to bad
it couldn't care less for that mutation
but it's environment specific so now
that it's moving from human to human
whoo-hoo it's moving way better like by
orders of magnitude what do you okay so
so you're like tracking this
evolutionary dynamics
which is fascinating but what do you do
with that
so what does that mean what does this
mean what do you make
what do you make of this mutation in uh
trying to anticipate i guess
is is the is one of the things you're
trying to do is anticipate
where how this unrolls into the future
this this
evolutionary dynamics such a great
question so so there's there's two
things
remember when i was saying earlier
mutation is the path
to new things but also the path to break
old things
so what we know is that this position
was extremely preserved
through gazillions of mutations that
mutation was never tolerated when it was
moving from baths to bats
so that basically means that that mate
that position is extremely important
in the function of that protein that's
the first thing it tells the second one
is that
that position was very well suited to
bat transmission but now
is not well suited to human transmission
so it got rid of it and it now has a new
version
of that amino acid that basically makes
it much easier to transmit from human to
human
so in terms of the
evolutionary history teaching us about
the future
it basically tells us here's the regions
that are
currently mutating here's the regions
that are most likely to imitate going
forward
as you're building a vaccine here's what
you should be focusing on
in terms of the most stable regions that
are the least likely to mutate
or here's the newly evolved functions
that are the most likely to be important
because they've overcome these local
maximum that it had reached in the in
the
bat transmission so anyway it's a
tangent to basically say that
evolution works in messy ways and the
thing that
you would break is the
thing that actually allows you to first
go through a lull
and then reaching new local maximum
and i often like to say that if
engineers
had basically designed evolution we
would still be
perfectly replicating bacteria
because it's by making the bacterium
worse that you allow evolution to reach
a new
optimum that's just a pause on that
that's so profound
the the that's so profound for the
entirety of
this scientific and engineering
disciplines
exactly we as engineers need to embrace
breaking things
we as engineers need to embrace
robustness as the first principle
beyond perfection because nothing is
going to ever be perfect
and when you're sending a satellite to
mars when something goes wrong
it'll break down as opposed to building
systems that tolerate failure
and are resilient to that
and in fact get better through that so
the spacex approach versus nasa
for the for example
is there something we can learn about
the incredible
uh take lessons from the incredible
biological systems in their resilience
in their in the mushiness the messiness
to uh
to our computing systems to uh to our
computers it would basically be starting
from scratch in many ways
it would basically be building new
paradigms
that don't try to get the right answer
all the time
but try to get the right answer most of
the time or a lot of the time
do you see deep learning systems in the
whole world of machine learning is kind
of taking a step in that direction
absolutely absolutely basically by
allowing
this much more natural evolution of
these parameters you basically
and then if you look at sort of deep
learning systems again they're not
inspired by the
genome aspect of biology they're
inspired by the brain aspect of biology
and again i want you to pause for a
second and
realize the complexity of the entire
human brain
with trillions of connections within our
you know neurons
with millions of cells talking to each
other
is still encoded within that same genome
that same genome encodes every single
freaking cell type
of the entire body every single cell is
encoded by the same code
and yet specialization
allows you to have this single
viral-like genome that self-replicates
the single module modular automaton
work with other copies of itself it's
mind-boggling
create complex organs through which
blood flows
and what is that blood the same freaking
genome
create organs that communicate with each
other
and what are these organs the exact same
genome
create a brain that is innervated
by massive amounts of blood pumping
energy to it
20 of our energetic needs
to the brain from the same genome and
all of the neuronal connections
all of the auxiliary cells all of the
immune cells
the astrocytes the ligand size the
neurons the excitatory the inhibitory
neurons all of the different classes of
parasites
the blood-brain barrier all of that same
genome
one way to see that in a sad
so this one is beautiful the sad thing
is thinking about the trillions
of organisms that died to create that
you mean on the evolutionary path and
the evolutionary path to humans
it's crazy there's two descendant of
apes just
talking on the podcast okay it's just
so mind-boggling just just to boggle our
minds a little bit more
yeah us talking to each other
we are basically generating a series of
vocal utterances
through our pulsating of vocal cords
received through this the people who
listen to this are taking a completely
different
path to that information transfer yet
through language
but imagine if we could connect these
brains
directly to each other the
amount of information that i'm
condensing into a small number of words
is a huge funnel which then you receive
and you expand into a huge number of
thoughts
from that small funnel
in many ways engineers would love to
have the whole information transfer
just take the whole set of neurons and
throw them away i mean throw them to the
other person
this might actually not be better
because in
your misinterpretation of every word
that i'm saying
you are creating new interpretation that
might actually be way better than what i
meant to the first place
the ambiguity of language perhaps
might be the secret to creativity
every single time you work on a project
by yourself
you only bounce ideas with one person
and
your neurons are basically fully
cognizant of what these ideas are
but the moment you interact with another
person the
misinterpretations that happen might be
the most creative part of the process
with my students every time we have a
research meeting i very often
pause and say let me repeat what you
just said
in a different way and i sort of go on
and brainstorm
with what they were saying but by the
third time
it's not what they were saying at all
and when they pick up what i'm saying
you're like oh
well now they they've sort of learned
something very different from what i was
saying and that is the same kind of
messiness that i'm describing in the
genome itself
it's sort of embracing the messiness and
that's a feature not a book
exactly and in the same way when you're
thinking about sort of these deep
learning systems
that will allow us to sort of be more
creative perhaps or
learn better approximations of these
complex functions
again tuned to the universe that we
inhabit
you have to embrace the breaking you
have to embrace the
you know how do we get out of these
local optima and a lot of the
design paradigms that have made deep
learning so successful
are ways to get away from that ways to
get
better training by sort of sending long
range messages
these lstm models and the
you know sort of feed forward loops that
you know sort of jump through layers of
a convolutional neural network
all of these things are basically ways
to push you out of this local
maxima and that's sort of what evolution
does that's what language does that's
what conversation and brainstorming does
that's what our brain does so you know
this
design paradigm is something that's
pervasive and yet not taught in schools
not taught in engineering schools where
everything is minutely modularized
to make sure that we never deviate from
you know whatever signal we're trying to
emit
as opposed to let all hell breaks loose
because that's the way that's the path
of paradise
the path to paradise yeah i mean it's
difficult to know how to teach that and
uh what to do with it i mean it's um
it's difficult to know how to build up a
sign the scientific method
around messiness i mean
it's not all messiness we need we need
some cleanness
and going back to the example with mars
that's probably the place where i want
to sort of
moderate error as much as possible and
sort of control the environment as much
as possible but if you're trying to
repopulate mars
well maybe messiness is a good thing
then
you